can you walk the audience through the
choice of the cover design we'll put up
a picture of it
and and even the title of the book let's
start there yeah so well the title you
see this is a biography of Galileo but
because Galileo had to deal with all
kinds of science deniers and because
science denialism is the way I see it a
big problem today then this is what
determined the title Galileo and the
science deniers namely it's a biography
of Galileo but with an eye on science
denial today so that's about the title
concerning the image on the cover so I
chose the very first portrait of Galileo
when he was relatively young probably in
his 40s it was done by an unknown Tuscan
painter but it's the very first portrait
known of him
usually people you know are familiar
with pictures of him by sister Mons when
he was all even there is one attributed
to Tintoretto and he was sort of middle
aged this one is is is the earliest so
that's that and then there are these
there is this figure of orbits of
planets around the Sun and the way the
cover was chosen is that his picture is
in the middle of that which makes it
look almost as if he is in the bullseye
of a target which kind of describes his
life